[Music]
welcome to episode three of the addie
hour
for any of you who are new listeners
happy to have you joining in with this
podcast conversation
really encourage you also to check out
our first conversations from the first
two episodes
i think you'll really enjoy some of the
depth that we were able to jump into in
both of those
but for today's episode really excited
to welcome to guests and we're going to
be discussing
topics related to stigma mental health
disparities
youth and suicide prevention so clearly
some heavy topics but some important
topics that we need to discuss as well
and i'm really honored to welcome
today's two guests the first is dr alfie
breeland noble
dr alfie is an internationally
recognized mental health expert
scientist author speaker and media
contributor
she's also the founder of the akoma
project and the host of the couchstone
color podcast
where she focuses on mental health and
bypoc youth
and more generally in marginalized
communities and in marginalized youth as
well
one of the things i really admire about
dr alfie is her effectiveness and skill
in translating complex scientific
concepts into everyday language
i think that's a rare commodity
unfortunately but i'm really thrilled
that she's so skilled in that and that
she's willing to jump in
to today's conversation so thanks for
being here of course my pleasure
our second guest is uh doug middleton
doug i almost gave you a doctor title
just kind of followed up maybe maybe i'm
speaking that into the future
there you go i'm a degree away so i got
a little
i got a little work to do that works
that works doug is an nfl safety for the
jacksonville jaguars and he's also a
mental health advocate who is all about
action
as the founder of the dream the
impossible foundation
doug has been bringing mental health
awareness to communities to high schools
to universities and specifically to the
african-american community
so he's used his platform to really
address things like mental health risk
factors to talk about access to mental
health services
and he also has a large emphasis on
youth development
he's partnered with many different
groups one of which is the national
alliance on mental illness
so i'm thrilled to welcome dr doug to
the program today
i'm just gonna keep rolling
we speak those things into the future
and to be and to be clear i mean some of
the work that you're doing already is so
impactful both of you so i'm just
honored that you're both willing to jump
into this conversation
appreciate you having us yeah so i
thought it would also be helpful for our
listeners for any who might not be
familiar with you all just to get to
know you a little bit and to just talk
about where we are as a society
at this moment clearly it's been a
challenging few weeks
in the country especially with the
tragic shootings in atlanta
and then of course following up with
tragic shootings in boulder
um and so in a lot of ways i mean we're
all still going through as a society a
level of
loss and mourning around those two
issues and especially whenever there's a
mass shooting
and all the trauma that can come from
that but all the different emotions that
come in time with that as well so i
thought just to be honest and have
people have both of you just share how
you're doing right now in the midst of
everything that's going on
um so dr alfie we can go ahead and start
with you okay sure
um so a couple things one thing i think
is a little odd i'll start there for me
in terms of my response and i'm sure i'm
not alone
but i think because i am a black woman
the response that i have
had to the two different shootings
really centers around this idea of
how do we respond to people who commit
these acts when these people are of
different racial ethnic groups
and so the first thing i heard first of
all muslim is not a race
right islam is a religion um and
to hear people talk about the second
shooter
in that context it upset me number one
the number two i look at
the excuses that people made for the
white male
who shot those poor people including
mostly asian women you know he was
having a bit like i literally watched
that and like it makes me teary just
sitting here thinking about it i was so
i was livid when i watched that i think
i even tweeted and put it on social
media like this is how you describe
people he had a bad day
we all have bad days all three of us
have had bad days it never occurred to
me to go pick up a gun and shoot
somebody
because i was having a bad day so that
really hurt me because i have close
girlfriends
who are asian american my goddaughter
um he's asian american filipino and
you know they're just people in my life
who i know are deeply impacted by so it
just
i hurt because they hurt and then on top
of
all of that being black we're still
going through it like it's like
every day it's something else then we
always going through it so i think
it's all of those things together it's
just like the perfect storm of
awfulness on top of the pandemic and
being stuck in the house and so
all of those things together it's just
made it really heavy so i've had to work
really hard to
keep my own mental health in check and
keep you know just kind of keep myself
grounded so i believe in meditation
i meditated before we even started
recording so that's what it's been for
me just really trying to pay attention
to because you know we're healers all
three of us the work that we do is in
healing
and sometimes when you're a healer
you're given so much
i think we can forget to take care of we
got to heal ourselves too
so that's been my thing trying to pay
attention and be attention to that and
be mindful of how i need to take care of
myself yeah
yeah i mean those are all so important
all those pieces i mean like you
mentioned too this is not happening in
isolation
everything we've already experienced in
the last year and then you know
obviously for us as black people all the
things that we experience on a daily
basis
trying to walk through i mean i think
there's a level of empathy
that we're able to have in these
situations not to say that others can't
have that too but just
some of those common experiences and
then to see like you said how how
some of that can be dismissed and the
focus just shifts away from the victims
instead of where it needs to be so i
appreciate your honesty
and sharing that what about you doug i
think for me
um one of the things that i've been
focused on the most
um over i mean really since
you know really started to happen is
really controlling what i
you know what i give myself access to um
i think that's that's something i've
really focused very hard on because i
mean you can turn on the news every day
and see something
you know horrible going on in your
community you can see something horrible
going on the other side of the country
and yes i'm you know emotionally
affected by you know the shootings uh
that's taking place in colorado and
georgia
um but to not mention that i mean
african americans have have
have been suffering a lot this year um
you know with kovitz so
you know i definitely don't agree with
any things that's going on in this
country but at the same time i have to
start to control some of the things that
i see because
i mean it's it's every day that it's
something you know it's every day that
is something that's going on
on that somebody's being killed and
somebody's being hurt and
like you said as you know as healers you
know it's hard to not want to feel like
you know we want to do something to
change that um
i even flashed back to um on george
floyd
um you know during during that incident
and
how i felt when i was on vacation um i
was on vacation with my fiance and
we like logged onto twitter and just
seeing all the videos and stuff and like
like every time you looked it was it was
just something there and it was like we
couldn't even really enjoy our vacation
we really just left and went home
because
um you know we felt like we had to do
something you know and
that moment right there kind of showed
me how i have to control the things that
i see and how much it
impacts my own personal mental health so
um
for me i see those things and i try to
do the best that i can to heal
and and make a difference um but at the
same time there's only so much that i
can do
you know i i can't go out there and and
change
uh gun control policies i can't go out
there and change the way people feel
about
other ethnicities you know so it's it's
tough you know and
um you know i i think the best thing
that i can do is focus on the things
that i can change from day to day
um i mean even things as small as you
know
one of my tennis dog died and and that
was the only thing she had when she
moved over here
um you know she had a tough breakup and
she moved on the other side of the
country after it
and the only thing she's had is her dog
for the last 12 years and
people might say oh that's just
something small i mean that's that's
something huge to her that's something
huge to me
so you know um it's just so much going
on it's it's
you really have to control what you put
into your mind and what you you know
give yourself access to
yeah that's so true and like you said
it's that balancing act too because if
you're
empathetic and being a healer you still
want to be able to reach out but
if your tank's completely empty then
you're not going to be any good for
anybody else so yeah
and dr alfa i know you've talked about
that too a lot in terms of the same
thing that was mentioned how much we
consume
like where do we set those boundaries to
be informed but not just be so
overwhelmed with it that it just drags
us down to a place that we can't
heal others and then at the same time i
mean you know we're healers but we also
need to be healed so we're still
both things are happening at the same
time it's not like we're always in that
place of full healing and going out to
help others we're still
like you said doug kind of going through
it ourselves too so definitely bouncing
it
yeah for me i know like you know if i
see too much like
if i sometimes i try to help but if i
see too much and it's so much going on i
just shut down because it's like
well is my impact even making a
difference am i even like you know
creating change or it's like is there so
much going on that i'll never be able to
help people so
that's kind of why i personally have to
filter some of the things that i see
because
it prevents me from from shutting down
and kind of just like
going into reserve mode where i realized
that there's nothing really i can do the
world's gonna be the way it is you know
yeah but what i like about what doug is
saying is
as a person who's a mental health
advocate the recognition that you do
have to
i phrase it as curating your news so you
have to be careful just like doug said i
can't say it any better
about how much you consume you also want
to be
careful about what you consume right so
i tell people i still haven't to this
day watch the video
of george floyd and the closest i came
was you know
i was blessed i had an opportunity to do
cnn like literally i think it was that
week
and they showed it and i like literally
wouldn't look i just didn't look at the
screen while they were showing except
i don't want to see that and so because
i know me i'm anxious and so that would
be stuck in my brain
forever once you see it you can't unsee
it and then people will say stuff like
yeah but you ain't woke if you don't
you know you ain't down but i'm like nah
man i'm more woke if i take care of
myself because if i take care of myself
on the front end i can have a longer
opportunity and more opportunity to go
have an
impact but if i'm like riddled and like
curled up in a ball because i just
because of how awful it was and thinking
about his little girl and i'm just
like all of that like how many people
are hurt because of that and it was so
senseless like over a day going dollar
bill or something so
i have to be careful about the ways in
which i consume it and so i would just
add to what doug said i tell people you
can't watch
that stuff all the time if you want to
be informed sometimes you need to just
go to a website and read or pick up you
know for who anybody who does use the
newspaper pick up a piece of paper
and read because then you have a little
bit more control but just sitting and
watching
i'm with him i can't do it yeah exactly
right
yeah that's important so i mean all
these topics are so
so critical and i'm curious how because
both of you have so much work that you
do with youth
so if you could actually share a little
bit about your journey into that work
and then also talk about some of these
principles and how
those come together like how do you pass
on some of this knowledge to the youth
that you're working with
okay um says gentlemen i love it
just gentlemen i just i just eat it up i
need to get my sunny hair
like this i treat women um but i thank
you for that doug
so a coma project long story short
really came out of
a research lab that i had i founded it
in 1999
when i was three i'm just kidding and so
um when i founded the lab
we were really all about trying to
understand how do we
encourage black youth specifically my i
really started my thing with black kids
so a coma started
as the acronym african-american
knowledge
optimized for mindfully healthy
adolescents so my whole thing was just
what can we do to help
our young black kids build their brains
build their not just resilience but
learn how to take care of themselves
emotionally because back then that was
the 90s nobody was talking about it like
we talked about it now it just was not a
thing
and as a black person was my white
colleague you know god bless them but my
white colleagues would say things like
well
how's depression anxiety any different
in black kids than it is than anybody
else
and my thing would be well you know we
don't have to unpack that a little bit
because black children specifically and
other kids of color have to deal with
racism and discrimination
so for one that's a huge difference not
to mention when you layer on
multiple identities like gender
identities or sexual orientation or you
know whether people are gender
conforming or not and so
that was really where we started how do
we get kids into care
at the time i said it's not my job to
fix what's provided once they get into
care once they get in their bottom in
that chair
now it is some of that too but it's like
we got to get them in because they can't
benefit from the treatments if nobody's
going
right so that's where we started over
time we evolved and then
in 2019 20 years later we became a
full-fledged 501c3 so i stopped being a
traditional academic lots of people have
heard me tell the story
because it was in my experience on the
end of one it was too restrictive
and so i couldn't do the kinds of things
i wanted to do like
name racial trauma as an issue that
impacts black kids
and kids of color and study that and so
i said okay i gotta do something
different so i left traditional academia
after
17 18 years in departments of psychiatry
and we turned a coma into a non-profit
and now what a coma is focused on is
three things
we raise consciousness right so we want
to raise people's awareness about these
issues of mental health just like doug
and what he does
we empower people because y'all we know
we know we look like
and we know how many of us are never
going to see a mental health
professional we try to change that
but we know as of today there are many
who are never going to go
and so we want people to have tools they
can use in the interim so if they never
get in
you know in your office like they're
addie if they never get with somebody
like doug who can get them into you know
direct them to care
um we want them to be able to do
something to take care of themselves and
the most important thing i feel like we
do
is we work to change the system we work
to shift the system we want the system
to be
something the mental health system in
particular to be a place
where black people and people of color
feel welcome where when you walk in
if you speak you know to god like i grew
up in a very heavily filipino community
in virginia beach virginia
close to pharrell williams and um
timberland we all live within like a
seven eight mile radius of each other um
and so in that community
the populations that were the biggest
that were of color were filipino not
just asian it was filipinos
um because of the navy and black folks
and so
you know you know we want to make sure
that the system is set up such that if i
speak to garlic
i should be able to find a provider who
speaks to college at least enough to
help me do some therapy
or who knows enough about different
cultures you can't know everything there
is to know about every culture that's
impossible
but you can be open right i can learn
how to say salamat and thank you you
know which is thank you in
tagalog or i can learn how to say
mihawkita which is i love you in tagalog
um because that little bit of phrasing
is going to let somebody know that i see
them
and to me that's the most important
thing we need systems that allow
our people to feel seen to feel valued
and to feel heard so that's what we're
about at a coma and we're all about
research and outreach
in those areas yeah i love it good
yeah um for me how i got into the space
and
and kind of the work that i'm doing um
you know one of my best friends well
my best friend since the age of six um
aj morrison we lived on the same street
uh together in winston-salem uh where i
grew up at and and went to high school
together
and um you know as we went to college uh
our past began to change a little bit
and aj started to suffer from severe
depression
um during that time my mom you know had
already had a lot a lot of history
in the mental health space and my
brother was starting to transition and
get into that space
right now he's a behavioral health
crisis counselor uh but
you know there were certain resources
that aj needed
uh that we didn't really have access to
or we really didn't know
you know what was what would work for
him and i think that's
you know just to go from the tangent
real quick i think that's what um
what scares people away from you know
going to see
people and get help it's like they they
think like the first counsel of the
therapist that you see is supposed to
work
and sometimes it takes maybe seeing four
or five different therapists and
counselors before you find some
effective therapy
uh same as with you know medicine um i
think
that was one of the issues that he had
is he saw
uh you know just a learning lesson from
his situation you know for me
um he saw a therapist you know he was on
pacific
medicine but that wasn't the correct
medicine for him
you know maybe he had needed to try two
or three more things but
at the time we weren't really aware um
and and
since that was you know four years ago
and since that time i've learned
a lot more about mental health and about
effective therapy
and effective medicine so um
since that since that time a couple
months later fast forward today
aj suffered a death by suicide and then
i spoke at his funeral
and um spoke about mental health um in
the african
community um you know all you know
pretty much all
african-americans there um and
i spoke about you know depression
anxiety
uh trauma uh and the things that aj was
going through and how
you know you can you know pair up you
know therapy and going to see somebody
and there's you know professionals in
the space and
i tried to do all that and immediately
after i got out the pulpit
the pastor caught up and he said hey
like you know that all sounds good but
you know you just need to pray about it
and bring all your burdens to the lord
and
and you know he you know take care of
that and and
that is what really made me get into
this
um get into the space because right
after that there was a ton of people
that came up to me and were like hey
i'm suffering too like i you know i need
help like you know what resources are
out there and it's like
you know in our community the stigma is
so strong and like it's even the same
way with my grandma like
you know how she was raised and you know
how you know
as generations were raised it's like you
know we look up so much to our pastors
and
and religion and and i'm a big believer
i'm a huge christian but i was always
taught you know for my mom that is
prayer
plus therapy of prayer plus it's not
just one you know one thing or another
like i wouldn't
put all these professionals or these
experts on this earth if it was just you
know only something that you could take
to god so
um that's how i kind of got into the
mental health space and then
um you know i wanted to just make a
difference in the african-american
community
and then after i had a few uh season
ending injuries in the nfl
i started to experience my own mental
health you know
mental health i guess i don't know
situations and
um that's when i really want to focus on
student athletes professional athletes
and helping them empower themselves
through
careers outside of football um you know
being able to feel purposeful you know
through their transition
um from you know the game into whatever
that they do next
and um that's kind of where we are now
um you know what i'm doing my foundation
now is
working with um african american
athletes at uh from really white
institutions
and just helping them empower themselves
and
figure out how to leverage the the
environments that they're in um
to lead to success after after they're
done playing a sport so
um yeah that's that's pretty much the
spiel
um and then i don't know that's i don't
want to go too long into it but
that's it that's so good definitely
appreciate your passion that i mean one
thing
the theme that kind of cuts across both
of what you're talking about is just
that theme of being seen
like making sure one that people are
seeing in the first place and that they
know
what tools are available at their
disposal because like you said
the prayer it doesn't remove the prayer
but we also have all these tools that
god's provided all the expertise that
we've been able to develop through
neuroscience psychology psychiatry
therapy social work
there's no need to ignore all that when
it's right there um from us but dr alfie
your point too about i mean
that could be a whole other conversation
if we talk about where the stigma
started
and why we don't access those services
um
but yeah i mean all those things are
part part of the conversation so i'm
i'm deeply appreciative both both the
efforts that both of you done to really
make sure
that folks are seen and that they know
that there are options
in that way i'll just elaborate on that
a little bit like what have you seen
that's been effective
either one of you in terms of making
sure that people are seen
and helping people kind of transition to
taking advantage of the resources
one of the things that i use um
and you know with a lot of college and
you know high school athletes or
you know professional athletes is group
therapy um group therapy has been
a very effective um method for us
and and one of the ways that i mean by
group therapy so
we'll bring maybe three four counselors
in there um and then we'll have
everybody sit around
and in a circle and we pretty much just
share
like you know some of the things that
some experience that
you know these athletes may be having on
campus and
the crazy thing about it is
a lot of these athletes are suffering
alone or suffering in silence
and there's so many people that's in the
room or they're colleagues or other
athletes that can help them that suffer
suffering the same way
and so that's that's one thing i've i
really helped them notice is that the
fact of like
hey like you're suffering like you need
to reach out like if you reach out like
chances are
like the person across from you or one
of your teammates are probably suffering
from the same thing
so um i mean it was even things like hey
like i'm
the only black student in my class hey
like you know
i'm six hours away you know from from
home hey i'm like
you know um you know i get out i'm
getting all these looks by
you know people the other race on campus
like i i don't know how to even
conversate with people in the other race
and
and those things they they all
you know they were all suffering from
from similar experiences so it was like
you know once we found a way to connect
them and really you know share the
experiences together
um you know a year later they they've
you know much improved and
a lot of progress so that's one of the
effective ways and
of course you know anytime you talk
about changing the stigma it's
you know people want to identify people
that others look up to
and that way you can break down the
stigma and and that way that
um people don't see it as something that
you know oh
you know these people don't do that so
why would i do it you know so
um that's been an effective way but um
yeah i mean those are just two points i
would say yeah that's really good
what i what i'd like about what doug is
sharing is
definitely what shows up in the research
literature and that
is normalizing it by showing people
reflecting people giving people mirrors
so when they bring in multiple
counselors or they bring in multiple
people um who are of color
right the what you're doing is
normalizing for these young people there
are people out there who look just like
you
right or look like your cousin they're
your people in them right who do this
work
and so those people it's not always a
perfect match but they may be more
likely to understand what your
individual personalized experiences are
because there's universality to this
issue with this idea of
let's just keep it real being black at a
predominantly white institution i went
to three
right my undergrad is from howard so
that was heaven for four years and then
they i
dove out there into some of these other
spaces and it won't so heaven
right it's kind of the opposite and so
even little day-to-day stuff like we
talk about microaggressions
you know walking if you're an athlete
and everybody knows who you
are that compounds it right because
everybody knows who the athletes are
especially if you go to a pwi like one
of my degrees is from wisconsin
it was like 12 black people there and
now them 12 10 of them was athletes and
so you know and if you weren't an
athlete people assumed you were an
athlete because they had no
conceptualization
that black people can go to college
doing something other than anything
wrong with sports like i said my brother
played college ball
but that's not the only way that black
people go to college so my spouse whom i
met at wisconsin interestingly enough
was there getting a phd in math
and he's kind of a you know a bill a
heavy dude and the people like yeah you
played for the football team he was like
no
i'm here getting a phd in map and they
would look at them they were like
right they thought they were getting
pranked or something and so
that kind of stuff you can only have
that conversation with somebody who
understands what that feels like so no i
may not
you know as a mental health professional
understand what it feels like to be an
athlete
in that space right but i do understand
what it feels like to be the only black
girl in the class
right and anytime a conversation comes
up around anything related to race
everybody like this right like i don't
have all the answers for
everybody right that's not what i'm here
for and so
you know he's what he speaks to is this
idea of how do you normalize
this this concept of talking to people
about what's going on with you stop
internalizing it and holding on to it
and thinking that you have to fix it all
by yourself so i
that and that's in the literature that's
what we have to do with our young people
of color other things that i find are
helpful
are also echoing what doug said which is
people need to see somebody
um i think young people in particular
who's prominent
who has fame who whom they look up to
and admire
i think often that helps because it
helps young people see
not only are they not alone but your
circumstances alone don't dictate
whether or not you're struggling with
something psychologically
right so having money and fame and
fortune and being in the league
that don't protect you from from mental
illness right people struggle
and so i think that's key i think some
of the other things that we found from
our research with tacoma
is it's not just about racial matching
it is about this idea and i know you
know this dr addy
cultural competence so if you go see
somebody and you feel like they're not
even trying to understand who you are
you're going to vote with your feet
you're just going to leave right so if
you go in i'm a chocolate girl and i
start talking about light skin dark skin
they look like oh
but i thought all y'all was black true
story like nah fam
that's not how it works right and so i'm
gonna need you to like have a little bit
more knowledge about this stuff and so
though that's important as well i think
it's also important that we
test the interventions that we use the
way that we
share you know provide psychotherapy so
i heard you speak to dr
um neuroscience right so we have
neuroscience we have psychiatry
have psychology we have social work you
have nurse practitioners
having making sure that what we provide
is something that has been evaluated and
assessed
as relevant for the populations we serve
right
people want to know that like we assume
people don't have that much knowledge or
interest
sure they do i want to know what is the
stuff you're giving to me why are you
giving it to me
and how does it help people who look
like me right so that's important too
and then the final thing that i will say
just as an example there are many others
is finding the spaces where people
already are again this is full circle
because this goes back to what doug was
saying in the beginning
you bring the care to the people don't
always ask the people to go to the care
because it's stigmatized
so if you're stigmatized you should
assume i ain't trying to come up in
there where you at
so if you bring it to me maybe i'll look
at it a little differently and so one of
the things that we do
um this book in my background talks
about it too one approach is we do work
with churches
so we have to talk with pastors about
please just just what you said doug i've
heard that myself
don't get up in that pulpit and say
stuff like that here's another way you
can frame it or just don't say anything
about it if you don't believe in it
don't say anything because people are
watching you and if they hear you as the
pastor say
oh we'll do that you just need to pray
right jesus is your doctor
if they hear you say that that's what
they're gonna think um and so that
faith-based mental health promotion
um and finding other ways to go where
the people are bring the group therapy
to the young people
those are all super effective ways i
think to get us into care
i think um just to add on a couple of
points you said cause like
i was i was left when you talked about
the uh the athlete thing because
i mean you sound like you speak and
sound like you were sitting right in the
conversations that i had with these
so that was the biggest thing that i had
um when
when i was in college the biggest issue
that i had going appalachian state i
think it's like four percent
african-american
uh there's like no matter if you
got a hoodie on it says you play
football or anything at all like people
gonna look at you and say hey like
don't you play football i'm like how do
you even know that like you you can't
think of my name you can't think
anything but you just think because
i'm a black man on this campus like i
have to play some type of sport and
um you know that just that just really
stood out because like all the athletes
we were talking to they feel exactly
like that
and um the cultural competence thing i
think that's a huge point because
um i did a event for super bowl with
other like
nfl athletes they were talking about
mental health and and somebody commented
an accent like how can
you know somebody within you know from a
different background or race or
ethnicity
um really um i guess be a counselor or a
therapist to somebody
with a different race and and what are
you looking for
um you know when you reach out you know
for some when you're trying to get help
when somebody doesn't look like you
and i think that's a great point
cultural competence is
is being able to understand um you know
the issues that
you know the race may have that that you
may not really
you know know much about in the
beginning yeah and you can't be afraid
of it
right so if i if the brothers show up
like one of the things that always stood
out to me was i remember watching
brandon marshall's story
and then when they got to the part where
they showed the person who diagnosed him
it was an older white guy
and i thought to myself it would have
been not is anything wrong with that but
it would have been so nice for him to
have been paired with somebody
from his background right to sort of
talk him through
this is how what you bpd might show up
in somebody who looks like you now i'm
not saying the white guy didn't know
that
i can guess but i'm not saying he didn't
um so i just think it's important that
we have a diversity of people
available to brothers and sisters so
that they have choices right and just
like doug said if you've got to go to
three or four people
to find that person who's going to
understand you and and and with whom you
have a connection
we need to we gotta keep encouraging
people keep looking if that first one
don't work you shopping like you're
shopping for some shoes so
you a sneaker head you're gonna keep
looking keep looking and shopping for
those providers as well so i'm just glad
he brought that point up though about
with our athletes they need people who
look like them too so we have to press a
little bit for some of these
professional associations
go find some black and brown people
to bring into these teams to help these
young people because they need people
they can
relate to without having to explain
everything because that gets tiring
yeah you're exactly right you're both
exactly right because we can't you can't
just have that
you can't have all the onus be on the
the person who's coming
to therapy like they don't need to have
to bring they shouldn't be trying to
teach the provider about their situation
especially if someone's struggling
there's already too much too much going
on there
so i mean it's it's so important in so
many ways and it cuts across
everything too to dr alfie as you
mentioned so i mean for me as a
neuroscientist
it cuts across that too how are we
asking those questions and are we taking
all those things into consideration
or are we kind of fitting people into
one box and saying this is just the way
it is
and then even you know if we're looking
at specific mental health challenge
are we not even taking into account some
of the other factors that could
contribute to that so i think both of
these
all the points that you're all raising
are so so vile and important
and a big piece of that too is just i
mean
people said this in other sentences too
but when we're trying to help people get
access to resources or someone who will
care for them it's a matter of are those
people actually listening to your story
or are they just putting you in a box
and saying
this is what i think you are dealing
with without even hearing where you're
coming from
and i mean that ties into the cultural
competency too but that happens so often
no that's right i just when you said it
the first thing i thought is they see
doug on campus appalachian state we know
where appalachian state is like yeah
athlete
right and yeah he is but you don't know
me like that you don't know what i'm
here for i could be here getting a phd
in neuroscience right like dr addy so
yeah and and how othering that is right
it's not it's the ass that when you make
those assumptions
you make people feel like the other
because the idea is everybody here looks
like
if i'm white everybody here looks like
me so anybody who doesn't look like me
oh the only way i can conceive of you
being here is you have to be an athlete
on a scholarship
right and you know and so that's and
that's hurtful because we know
internally as the person on the
receiving end we know that's what people
think
right and we don't we don't want to live
like that so bad stuff weighs on your
psyche in addition to looking around
and as we used to say my family's from
mississippi you to fly in the buttermilk
i don't want to be flying the buttermilk
that ain't comfortable that's not fun
um so i just when you said that dr addy
it just made me think
it's that othering piece that i think
can be really hard and make it and make
it really difficult and challenging for
people
i think one thing that's great that
you're both doing is you're building
community too
i mean doug even when you were talking
about the group therapy like that's
giving people community they're coming
out of isolation
like oh that person's dealing with the
same thing that i'm dealing with but
if nobody voices it then no one hears
that and you know going back to the
neuroscience too i mean there's so much
evidence about how community actually
shapes our brains
and makes it easier for us to deal with
some of these mental health challenges
so
i mean you're both you're both tapping
into that already yeah
we got the scientists supported too i
take it okay okay
i feel smart today thank you thank you
i'm learning from both of you too
on that note i was going to have you
both share a little bit too about what
what have you learned from the young
people that you've worked with because i
know this is a two-way street i mean
you're bringing obviously a lot of
knowledge and information to them but i
would imagine that there's things that
you take away that they teach you as
well
yeah so for me i think it's kind of easy
a couple things one is
young people are more eager to engage
and invest in this space than we give
them credit for
two they have loads of ideas if we just
listen to them
um without judgment just listen to them
right not everyday
ideas don't be perfect but not every
idea we present as adults is perfect for
them either
um three uh i feel like they're eager to
partner
if they're asked in the right way so we
kind of talked about that a little bit
when we started if you
ask nicely and if you ask
and then be quiet and listen they will
talk to you i think too often what young
people
what we've learned from our research is
that we as adults will
ask but then as soon as we finish asking
we're answering for
them we don't give them an opportunity
to express themselves so it's this idea
of
i call it active listening so first i
have to close my mouth
right and i love to talk so i have to
work on i just kind of sit on my hands
close my mouth
after i asked the question and listen
and you're listening
not as you're crafting an answer you're
listening to take in
and receive what the young people are
saying um so i'm learning i'm learning
how to listen from them and then the
final thing i would say
is i'm learning how to be more
unapologetic i like if nothing
i'm telling you the younger millennials
in gen z
ain't apologizing for being black or
being brown or being queer or whatever
it is and i have really truly learned
to stop apologizing for who i am and
just to like own it
and inherit it and inhabit it and and
stand in it and so
that's been really powerful for me um to
keep going right because there's so many
ways in which you know i'm going back to
my experiences as an academic people
were like yeah but
yeah we yeah we already know how to
treat depression we already know how to
treat anxiety
and i'm thinking but if you did we
wouldn't have these health disparities
we wouldn't have these differences and
who accesses care we wouldn't have
greater attrition or drop-off rates when
people are black
if you really knew what you were doing
so clearly you don't have the answers
so what i'm learning is to not apologize
for what it is that i want to study
and because these young people don't
apologize for who they are so they teach
me in those ways too so that's not
exactly the answer to the question but
that is what i'm learning from the young
people
that's a copy that's a great answer
because like
that's actually the same thing that i'm
learning from they're like
this generation is so resilient and like
i mean if you look i mean i keep going
back to this georgia floyd situation but
if you look at all the protests and all
everything that was going on
and like all this was kind of led by
young people those are the ones that
learn how to strategize and mobilize
and they know how to you know like even
you know a lot of the african-american
students on our campus that have stayed
they had a whole list of demands that
they wanted like they i mean
they don't they don't take no for answer
and uh i think that's kind of what i'm
learning for them is like
like how hard and how passionate um they
will work to get with
you know what they feel is right and and
how
they're not going to accept you know the
world being the same way that it is so
um yeah that's that's what i'm learning
from
yeah i agree with both of you i mean in
some way it's humbling too
so i mean i mean even looking at this
podcast you know i'm
10 plus years into my career i'm seeing
those that are coming up
doing stuff like this from the get-go
even while they're still training
i can't imagine so just you know just
the level of effort and like you said
just
i don't know who they are and saying
we're not going to take no for an answer
and really just jumping in and
making an impact early on it's inspiring
in a lot of ways
so the pivot just a little bit because i
know we want to still touch on because
both of you you know done aspects around
suicide prevention as well
i mean obviously that's not it's not a
light topic it's not an easy topic but
it's again the same thing where i feel
like
there's so much stigma associated with
it that oftentimes in so many circles it
just doesn't get talked about
it just gets ignored so people are kind
of left to their own whatever
concept they have about it so i just
wanted to ask both of you
like what what you've seen in terms of
trying to move the needle on that and
really
breaking that stigma so that people can
get to a place of really talking about i
guess we can start just
misconceptions that you've both noticed
in your work that people have around
suicide and suicide prevention
i guess one thing that i could talk
about just a quick little shout out so
one of my colleagues that's in this
space her name is fonda bryant
but she uses um this question persuade
referred to keep your train
um that's a huge thing that she loves to
do and um
it's really it's made it a really easy
way to like kind of
um you know give people a few steps that
that way they can help
learn how to prevent suicide um that's
that's one way
uh that i would you know some of the
education has taken place
and i guess the misconceptions is that
i know a lot of a lot of people think
that
you know when they commit you know when
they suffer
a death by suicide that the pain is
going to end you know like that that is
all going to go away and then they'll
just be able to start over and
that's not really the case um a lot of
people think that is
they they they have a a short-term
problem but they're they're trying to
fix it with a long-term solution
and and i think that's the misconception
around it and and
that's i mean that's that's kind of all
i really have to say about it because
i'm still
i still struggle with uh trying to find
some of the things that i could have
done better
um you know with my best friend's life
and and some of the ways i could have
provided him
uh with more steps or more uh access to
resources that that way
you know suicide wasn't really an option
um yeah i know that's not an easy topic
so definitely
just acknowledge that and appreciate you
being willing to go go to that place as
well because i think that empowers
a lot of people too just to continue to
break through those misconceptions and i
know that your foundation's
like a legacy foundation in a lot of
ways for uh for aj's life so
definitely appreciate the way you're
continuing to do that yeah about your
doctor coffee
yeah so first i want to just quickly i
meant to do it at the front end whole
space for doug
and the loss of your friend because
that's a lot it's a lot to carry
um and like dr addie appreciate you for
being
vocal and open and taking action to try
to do something
in his honor and the other thing i'll
say now this is the auntie
i'm sorry this is the auntie and me so
it's gonna come out
um but i think it's important for
the survivors of the ones who are still
here to understand
that when a person is determined to
complete a suicide
it's difficult for us to stop them but i
think the key is
when they're determined right not
everybody not even most people
are determined to complete it um i think
what people
what i've learned in terms of suicide
prevention is that people want to stop
the pain
they don't really want to die right i do
not believe that anybody
almost anybody who dies by suicide that
the goal is to die the goal is to stop
the pain
and just like you said doug it's a
permanent solution
to what often is a temporary problem but
sometimes a temporary goes on too long
for people
um and they just don't see any other way
out so what i've learned about suicide
prevention
is that being silent about it
about these are people's experiences
that
is not helpful especially for those of
us from
underserved communities or people of
color or black folks in particular
um i've also learned that
it is it's not a bad thing to talk about
it it's not a bad thing to ask the
question
you do not plant the idea in somebody's
head
when you ask them if they're feeling
suicidal are they having suicidal
thoughts
those are all things that i've learned
i've learned that it's important for
us as advocates as professionals as
loved ones to remember that
we can do everything in our power but we
cannot
fix people i tell people that you can't
fix other people the only thing we can
do is be present
be available always let them know that
we're there for them
try to find resources and tools to share
with them
educate ourselves so that we can become
more aware i think once we've done all
of that
we have to this is and this is another
auntie part we have to forgive ourselves
i have a really close girlfriend who
lost her son to suicide about
uh maybe 25 years ago
yeah 24 25 years ago and ever since then
she and i have been close partners we go
around and do a lot of advocating
internationally we've been to a couple
different places
and she shares her story about losing
her son
after losing her first husband in a car
accident so she believes that her son's
suicide was related to complicated grief
that he never was able to heal so when
he was six when he lost his dad and he
died by suicide at 15.
um and so those are just some of the
different things that i've learned about
suicide prevention but i think the most
important thing is one of the most
important things that i've learned is we
still don't know enough
about suicide prevention in black
communities specifically because we
don't have enough research out there now
we know anecdotally we know
you know how to have these conversations
in our community i
want non-profits and funders that's part
of why we're so invested in research
to go out there and do the work to give
us more ideas about how do we take care
of ourselves and part of that is
learning how to understand the
relationship between
racism discrimination all the isms
right of the phobias that people
experience
and suicide when you have the weight of
all those things compounding your
depression and
your anxiety or your trauma um i think
it can be
a really awful perfect storm that
contributes to it but we just have not
spent enough time and invested in this
country
in getting that knowledge to be able to
help people on
the scale that we would like to so
that's why what does what you do is so
critical
dr addy having this podcast is so
critical i know what i do again i'm
being unapologetic like young folk
what i do is so critical because we are
the ones who are going to put
a spotlight on this and show people
right so i hope if everybody lists those
people listen to this doug what they
hear you say
is y'all need to go get some therapists
and bring them
like ab state all these other white
schools bring them therapists to them
kids
in in a safe place for them stop asking
them to go over the caps
right um or accounts of psychological
services so things like that that's what
we have to do
um to support our young people and to
and to
help prevent suicide yeah
that's so important i mean so many so
many important aspects that you've both
brought out and
not easy like i've said several times
but i mean it's critical because like i
said if we don't talk about it
that's where things sit before they've
been both of what you're doing to really
move the conversation forward and move
the resources forward
um just make sure that people people
know so i mean it goes back to that
community in isolation too
and just making sure dr outfit like you
said that we're present and we're
willing to have those conversations so
another question i usually like to oh go
ahead i'll know if there's something
else you want to
you're good okay um i also just like to
ask folks you know in the midst of all
these challenges too what what gives you
hope especially
in the work that you're doing with the
young people you've hinted at some of
that already
but be curious for both of you to kind
of elaborate on that piece too
that's easy for me this right here gives
me hope
knowing that there are people younger
than me who care about this stuff who
are black
black black blackety black who care
about this stuff
that gives me hope because we know that
we're not alone and there can never be
too many of us doing this work so every
new foundation i see more power to you
because that's more of us to do the work
to reach more people
um me have being able to start the
foundation
um and to fundraise the way that we were
able to do in the first
year um that gives me hope and a lot of
our funding comes from people who are
not black
um and so that it gives me hope that
other people are paying attention
and care and want to help our young
people of color
those two things and then finally what
gives me hope is just
young people in general like just
knowing how again
they just inhabit their own space and
they know who they are and
like you said dr addie jumping out of
undergrad or
coming right out of or being in
residency or graduate school and they're
going to start their podcast so they're
going to start their own foundation
that gives me hope because it lets me
know that they are not
broken especially our kids of color by
the systems that
impact and weigh on them so heavily um
so but the most important thing today
that's giving me hope is being able to
be here with you too
that just gives me all the hope in the
world and so more power to both of you
wow that's mutual i can tell you that
yeah i would i would say the same points
the things that give me hope is is
just really seeing the progress um you
know with the
with the youth you know when you come in
um you spend time with them and then
you know a year later you see that
they're in a better space than they were
when you first met them
um and now they're ready to put some
action behind some of
the feelings and experiences that they
have and
um dr alfie to one of the points that
you said just
how many people gravitate towards um
you know a cause or um experience when
you may not even know
or they might not even be black or they
you don't even know why they do it but
you know somewhere down the line they
have made they have may had a friend or
experience that that really touched them
and that's
why um they want to join on on the call
so
just seeing people share that passion
with you know with me
um is something that really helps and
gives me hope and
and you know just seeing that things are
changing you know day by day and um
you just gotta continue taking one one
day at a time
that's so good well it's gonna sound
like a cliche but i know that
both of you give a lot of people hope
just in the work that you're doing
and to be completely honest i mean we
talked about this before we jumped on to
but
how quickly you both were willing to
jump on this podcast you
me personally that gives me a lot of
hope seeing what you all are doing
and i feel like in some ways i'm in a
place of privilege to be able to bring
all these different folks onto this
podcast to kind of amplify
what you all already doing because i
mean you're already doing the work this
is just you know another platform
to kind of bring those pieces together
and i think to talk about in a way that
doesn't always get as much
quote-unquote airplay so yeah i'm deeply
appreciative of both of you
i think this is going to go go a long
way i hope our listeners will uh will
feel that too when they listen to this
episode so
any closing pearls of wisdom from either
of you
you dropped a lot of those already yeah
uh the only thing i would add is curate
your news
and no i always want young people to
know if
you feel like at any moment nobody cares
that doug cares dr ada cares dr alfie
cares and you are seen
you are valued and you are heard we just
need you to know that
you're never alone that's that's what i
was saying you're never alone
there's so many people that care about
you and and
just find a good support system to put
around you um
you know that way um you know if you're
ever struggling if you ever
you know have a tough day you know some
people that can recognize that
you're going through that and be there
that help get you through it
so good so good mom and dad to both of
you
thanks again for jumping on the addi
hour this is going to bless a lot of
folks and
i know these conversations and i'm
looking forward just to continuing to
find the work that you're both doing too
and hopefully you all can connect in
your overlapping interest too i think
there's a lot absolutely
just there it's done thank you for
having us thank you thank you
[Music]
you